julia has been training to be a doctor
for four years
the past few months have been her
hardest
she's unvaccinated and faced having to
give up her career
even before it began
i'm already over 40 000 pounds of debt
from my first degree and i'm nearly on
the home stretch so it took a really big
time on mental health i've had to get
into therapy for additional support
because of this situation
but do you accept that the vaccines work
that they save lives they stop people
from getting very sick and ending up in
hospital with someone like me who is fit
healthy and young and who has already
had covid those were reasons for which
drove my my position to not take the
vaccine but now just days before julia
and her colleagues had to be vaccinated
once to meet the mandatory deadline
the government has reversed its decision
while vaccination remains our very best
line of defense against covert 19
i believe that it is no longer
proportionate to require vaccination as
a condition of deployment through
statute
the health secretary was confronted by
an unvaccinated doctor in a hospital
earlier this month what do you think of
the the new rule to require vaccination
i have not had a vaccination
i did not want to have a vaccination
and these views are shared by around 77
000
other nhs staff
workers the health service cannot afford
to lose
but around 95 percent of nhs workers
have had the jab the threat of losing
their jobs boosted this number i i
personally couldn't bear to go to work
knowing that i haven't done all i can to
protect protect patients who may be very
sick they may be having cancer
chemotherapy if i give them covet i may
i may take their life from them and i
just can't do that
and these are pressures the care sector
is all too aware of some 40 000 staff
are thought to have quit because of the
vaccine mandate that came into force in
november there are many people who have
had to make that decision already to
leave their jobs some of whom have been
working in those homes for many years
and they're not necessarily now in a
position where they're
going to be to come back to those roles
so we've already lost something as a
result of the policy julia can now look
forward to the career she's been
dreaming of
but now she and all nhs workers will be
hoping this u-turn does not cause any
long-lasting damage
to the health service
ashish joshi sky news